hey what's up guys my name is the
channel welcome back to my game engine
series today we're continuing on with
what we did last time last time we
talked about scene
serialization and the civilization check
out that video up there if you haven't
already
and today we're actually going to be
adding some ui to be able to
like open certain scenes to save as so
that we can save to a custom
file path and all that stuff instead of
the little test that we had what we
always
uh wrote to and read from the same exact
file
and we'll also be adding like a little
file new so that we can create a new
scene and then
build all that stuff up so it should be
pretty exciting let's
dive right into the code and get this
party started
so the first thing that i want to do is
um well let's let's
let's take a look at where we left off
probably useful so
um we have file and then serialize
deserialize that's all fine
if we press to serialize we'll load our
example.hazelfile and we can change
whatever we want to it so like let's
maybe
move the red square up a little bit and
then we can serialize it and then that
way
well first of all we have one problem if
we deserialize it again
you can see that it just simply adds
everything here it doesn't actually
uh you know create like a blank scene
for us but also
um uh obviously we're just we're dealing
with the
with one file like we're just that's not
how things work we want to be able to
like save to a certain file that we
specify
and load from a certain file that we
specify as well so let's take a look at
how we can do that
so the way again this is one of those
things that um
is going to be different depending on
who you ask
i personally do not like any kind of
weird implementation of an
open file or save file dialogue that is
dependent on the ui library you're using
that's weird i feel like if you're on
windows you should use the standard
windows
like open file save file dialog they're
there for a reason and they're really
easy to use
now obviously the downside is that
they're only on windows
right they're windows only so in other
words you can't you know if
it's going to involve using the windows
um api the win32 api
and obviously that's not going to work
on like a mac or anything like that but
that's okay
you can just implement it differently on
a mac it's not that hard and i think
that it's probably not worth using like
a third-party library for
you can nothing wrong with that but
we'll do it ourselves
so inside um core what i want to do is
actually no inside hazel here i'm going
to add a new folder called utils
um thanks visual studio
i don't know why you're being weird and
why you hate me so much oh there's
already folder called utils
oh that's probably from when i was
writing it on stream well that's fair
enough
all right in the utils folder i will add
a new item here called platform
utils right and this uh platform utility
that's what i call it yeah
platform utils is going to just be a
header file only that is going to be
implemented per
platform it's not going to be
implemented like we do like you know
vertex buffers and stuff
are we still on buffer i renamed it to
vertex buffer anyway
did that on in hazel dev well we'd like
to use some weird runtime switch we
don't need any of that because obviously
this stuff will only compile on the
platform you're compiling for
and then over here we will let's include
string
we will uh basically have a bunch of
utilities that are platform specific so
in this case i'm going to make one
called
file dialogues right and and this is a
class
purely for organizational purposes you
can have this as a function
if you want i just don't like the idea
of it floating around in
the hazelname space you could add
another namespace but
for this kind of stuff i just like using
classes to be honest static
scd string open file
and we'll take in a const char filter
here
right and then we'll have open file and
save file
this filter is going to be a way for us
to specify and we might have to change
this filter a little bit because it
might be different on different
platforms but for now we'll just use the
windows version
this filter is just going to basically
you know like when you save you know
let's just do control or maybe
you can see this kind of all files and
then you have a list of everything that
you can choose from that's what this
filter text is going to be
okay so let's implement this
so obviously this can't be implement
implemented in platform utils or cpp
we're going to do it in platform windows
and i'm going to add a new item here a
cpp file called
windows platform utils
include hz pch include uh
where is it hazel utils platform utils
namespace hazel and then obviously we're
going to implement these functions let's
copy them
let's copy file dialogs let's get rid of
static
and let's add them here okay and now we
are
ready to go so this will return a string
which is going to be the file path
the absolute file path because that's
what we return um
okay cool so we obviously need the win32
api for this now the specific file that
we're going to need actually
because this required some some
troubleshooting earlier
is c o m dialogue so common dialogues
is what that kind of stands for i guess
um this refers to the 32-bit common
dialogue apis okay so this is what
what they are windows only we're of
course in windows platform utils
so that header file should be present
and so should the code
now we're also going to need to include
glfw
because we basically need to when we
open a file dialog
it's parented to it to an existing
window right so
if i click here you can see it it
doesn't react right it doesn't let me
interact with this because i'm blocked
by a modal dialog
now this uh needs to basically know the
parent window
and we need to get the parent window
from glfw to get the actual h
wind the window handle that windows uses
we need to also basically define glfw
expose native win32
and then include gl fw
glf w3 native so the reason we do this
is because you can see that if this
is in fact defined it lets us get the
win32 things that we care about
such as the h1 and that's what we need
the window handle
so i'm just going to copy and paste this
from
the code that i wrote earlier this is
what open file looks like let's go
through this line by line
so we have an open file name i'm using
the ascii version
over here uh this let's just get rid of
these comments because they're
fairly useless um we'll zero memory that
struct because that structure has a
whole bunch of stuff and we want to uh
initialize it to zero um the struct size
we just have to set this for every win32
structure
how it works uh h wind owner so this
is now where we're getting glfw get
win32 window and then we need the actual
window
now we need the application class so
hazel core
application and then we simply do
application get get window get native
window we've already got that api
because i think we used it for like i
don't know what we used it for to be
honest
um let's uh get any window let's quickly
see what that's used
in because i'm actually oh inside excuse
me it's that i'm gooey layer
so we had to get the glfw window and
pass it into i'm gooey so it can hook up
into events and stuff like that
so that's what we use that for but then
we can also now feed it into a new
function
get win 32 window so that we can
actually um
so that we can actually uh get the h1n
back and set the
the owner of this new struct of this new
dialog
[Music]
let's see this is the file this is just
a buffer for the file the max file size
is of course
the max file of this you can just up
that if you want uh filter is whatever
we pass in here filter indexes
one i think this is basically which one
is
set by default or something like that
you can read this documentation online
this stuff's kind of important
so path must exist file must exist and
no change directory
this last flag is very important if you
don't do this funnily enough when you
call get open file name
it will actually change your working
directory of your application to be the
folder that you opened from
um this may or may not be okay depending
on what you want because if you're
loading files relative to a master file
that you've loaded maybe that's a good
thing
in most cases though i would like my
working directory to actually remain
you know the working directory that the
application has by default
which in if you run it through visual
studio is going to be this hazelnut
folder because the same folder
as the project file and if you look at
the
if you look at the under debugging if
you look at the working directory you
can see it's actually set to
project directory which is the directory
with the vcx proj file
otherwise if you run the exe file it's
usually going to be
well if you run the exe file it's the
it's the directory of the exe file
unless you have like a shortcut
and you change the start in to be a
different working directory anyway
probably make a whole video on working
directories but for now we'll
have no change directory which means
don't change my original working
directory because that will
most likely if you don't have this will
most likely once you've opened something
or saved something
it'll break all of your other file
loading for the rest of your application
because obviously it's going to be now
relative to a folder such as
asset scenes if you're opening a scene
file instead of
to the root that you would expect um
so get open file name a again using the
ascii version don't really need to use
the ascii version because it will use
the compile settings to figure it out
but we are here
um we might even want to use the wide
chart version for different languages
but that's just how it is for now
this might not work with other languages
uh equals true blah blah we return the
actual
um so once we've done that we return the
file path right and we create a
string implicitly out of this chart
pointer that's it
okay pretty simple stuff um again i
probably won't explain much of this code
because it's
basically identical it's just that we
use you can see that literally uses
the same struct um the only difference
is that we use get save file name
instead of get open file name and this
is our dialog so if it equals true
then we return this otherwise it's
important to know that we return an
empty string
right so if we get an empty string back
this
dialog has effectively been cancelled so
we need to handle that
right so um actually this is probably
something that
we should enforce so returns empty
string if cancelled
these return efficiency
empty strings if cancelled okay
important
stuff all right
so um going back to our editor layout
now we can actually
do this stuff which is pretty exciting
um
so inside editor layer i just want to
make sure that i'm
getting all the code right and i think i
am going a little bit off script here
um what we'll do is uh
scroll down to where we did the uh this
kind of stuff and we're going to change
these menu items
around a bit so we're going to have open
i like to have a
dot meaning that like a dialogue i think
that's the normal accepted convention
anyway for application programming at
least on windows that
if it has a dot dot it's going to open a
further dialog whereas if it doesn't
it's not
right so in other words if we
implemented a new which we will
uh this wouldn't have it because it's
just going to create a new one it's not
going to like open another dialogue
and then we'll have save as we won't
have saved for now um
i guess we can it doesn't really matter
if save is just going to be the
equivalent of instead of opening a
dialog it uses whatever the current path
is has been opened
or last saved as um it stores
the file path of that and it will just
save into that without asking you
uh so new and then we probably also want
to add shortcuts to this
i guess how much time are we going here
yeah 11 minutes all right let's do it in
this episode
so ctrl o will be the shortcut for open
control n will be the shortcut for this
and this will be ctrl shift s so i'm
gooey will actually render these helpers
for us which is nice
so open um so now what we do is we
basically do
uh let's include hazel
ute utils platform utils um
and then we'll do uh
file dialogs um
open file except let's do it down here
open file now the filter the filter that
we're going to use
and you may want to store this somewhere
i'm not sure where we'll store this but
i'll copy and paste it from here it's
going to be this and you can
figure out the format for this by
reading the win32 documentation
but basically what you need is some null
terminated strings here
um that uh are going to contain
like all of like the entire list of
types that you want to support right so
this is kind of like a convention that
just
happens and let me just um rephrase this
a little bit so this is actually
one file right there are two null
termination characters
but one is the text that appears in the
description
so in other words oops thing ctrl o
so this all files thing where you see
all files and the thing in brackets
that's this first string
the next string is the actual filter for
it to use to filter these files by
right so there are two different things
right um
so this text that you see here is
entirely the first string that's why you
need to put it like that and
it's nice to specify the type in
brackets because that way you know
exactly what a hazel scene file
is okay so that's what it is and
obviously we get a string back which is
the file path
so when we get that string back we need
to check to see if it's empty
because if it is empty so if not empty
will write
if it is empty then the dialog has been
cancelled or the file is somehow
empty path which is wrong anyway so we
only do the
the this is supposed to do deserialize
we only do deserialize
from the file path if
it's empty sorry if it's not empty right
because if it's empty that's wrong
now speaking of which we need to create
a new scene here so active scene uh
equals
what do we do here i think it's just
create ref right
create ref scene so that's how we create
a new empty scene
and we'll actually probably move this
into a function in a minute
uh because we also want to call this
code when we press ctrl o i'm gooey's
not going to do that for us
um so we need to uh we'll we'll kind of
copy this into another function so that
we can also call it from our shortcut
code
um so we'll do we'll create a new thing
and then we actually need to do
on viewport resize to resize it to the
current viewport size because if we
don't do that
then our cameras aren't going to render
properly
and we actually probably need to defer
our cameras being created
being uh recalculated with the matrices
but we'll we'll see how that works out
so peoplesize.x
okay so there's our viewport size um and
then we need to
also set the context of our scene
hierarchy panel
to be our new active scene because we've
recreated it right
okay there we go so when we have
multiple tabs by the way if we have
multiple scenes open at once and we have
multiple tabs every time we switch tab
we're going to have to reset the context
of the scene hierarchy panel
that should be pretty easy obviously
that's it that's our whole
decentralization code and really not
that hard um
let's do new while we're at it again
this is basically just gonna do this
right in fact we could uh move this out
into like new scene and then
call a new scene and then yeah you get
the point
save as save as is also pretty simple
instead of
[Music]
doing open file we do save file with the
exact same filter
and then if the file path isn't empty
guess what we
serialize into the file path
it's actually a lot easier though
because we don't really need to um
we don't really need to do any kind of
like active scene changing because
obviously we're working on the current
scene we're just saving it as
that's it let's open let's run this
and if we do file you can see we have
file new open save as
you can add separators by the way to the
menu items you might want to do that if
you want to look
even prettier but i think it's fine for
now so if we do open
we should now be able to navigate to
assets scenes and example.hazel
beautiful there it is right if we do new
we should go back to a new scene
good let's do open again um and then
let's
uh maybe let's oh here's a curveball
let's switch to a different camera
and maybe let's make this a perspective
camera and let's move it like back a
little bit
um and then it will be really cool with
this and
uh let's move it a bit this way but
we'll be really cool with this and we'll
also
um move maybe the green square a bit
further back right
so it's actually going to be smaller
cool let's save that as
uh we'll do 3d example because that is
actually 3d
3d example save okay so now if i go new
oh good an error that's actually i'm not
joking when i say good because i want to
cash as many bugs as possible
so this is uh okay this is that this is
fine
so this is an error that happens when we
uh basically try and create a new scene
but we don't reset the scene hierarchy
panel's context
or rather the selected item so we have a
selection context here
and obviously if it's present the
properties panel is always going to want
to draw that entity
what we've just done is deleted our
whole scene because we've pressed new so
it's deleted the old scene
but the selection context is still
pointing to an entity of that old scene
that's now been deleted
and thus we get a crash so to reproduce
this and to make sure that i'm right in
what i just said
i know i am because i've gone through
this before in the live stream but for
you guys
um if we open this if we select an
entity here and then go file new
there's that crash again okay so the way
that we fix that is
pretty simple um when we
reset the scene's context so something
else
we need to clear the selection context
now this is where it gets a little bit
tricky as well because
you might want the selection context to
go along with the scene
so in other words if you have multiple
tabs and you switch between them you
probably want to maybe switch to what
you have selected last in your scene
maybe it's up to you but obviously we're
not doing tabs or anything yet so we'll
just do that that's the easy fix
and now obviously if i was to uh
try and repro that bug file open
[Music]
example and then i'll select camera file
new you can see it works fine
so let's open our first hour example and
then we'll actually open our 3d example
and you can see everything works now
i've prepared a little special treat
for you guys if you can call it that um
inside on my desktop i have a file that
i created during
um a live stream uh when i was working
this stuff out just to test it and it's
like kind of like a little 3d cube
so if i go file open and let's go to
it's completely different directory now
right
pink cube.hazel let's open that check
that out we now have a
3d cube inside hazel so what this
actually is by the way
is three quads right we have the camera
we have the top the right and the left
quad
of varying different colors so they're
kind of a pink color that gets darker
and darker
right um and i've just kind of rotated
them and positioned them like in a
slightly
different place uh so that it kind of
looks like a 3d coupe so surprise
it's not really 3d rendering from a
model or anything like that with actual
lighting in the shader but it kind of
looks like it is which is cool
and um this obviously proves that we can
load this because i actually made this
scene file
in like the version of hazel before i
reverted to then record these videos
so yeah definitely pretty cool this is
gonna be the thumbnail for the video
massive click bait maybe but whatever um
that is how
that works uh is there anything else in
this episode that i wanted to do
i don't believe so everything looks yeah
the camera was supposedly not working
but i think it is now
so um because i must have fixed that in
the other episode maybe
okay anyway it doesn't matter uh
everything looks like it's great let's
go file new
again and let's open the pink cube again
yeah everything's working great
um that is uh now really usable we can
go file new oh the shortcuts
i don't know if anyone said anything but
no okay good um
okay the shortcuts also really simple to
make obviously
uh if we go into editor layer and we
look at our events
so at the moment we have on event let's
go ahead and and actually create an
event dispatcher
[Music]
and then we want to do
dispatcher.dispatch
um and this will be a
i guess uh key pressed
event
and then how do we i need to maybe i'll
search this code
because i don't know if we replace the
way that we dispatch things
we still use h said bind event but i
think maybe that that creates lambda for
us
so that's pretty easy okay so we'll just
use that um
probably should rewrite this whole thing
but doesn't matter so we'll grab this
um and we'll go back to edit a layer key
pressed event
so this will be editor layer
on key pressed
uh and then let's see
um obviously we this needs to be
effectively on the first key press so
it's kind of like a keep typed thing in
a way but it's really just um
with a repeat count of zero so void oh
sorry bull on
key pressed key pressed event
e um
i don't know if that's all kind of uh
included but we'll see
okay so we do that um and then i don't
even know if we need camera controller
that might not be used anymore
but anyway regardless so uh if here's
what we can do
switch uh that's cool little automation
here
e dot get key code
now this is um these these are kind of
like our shortcuts
i'll see i'll say and for the shortcuts
if
the repeat count is greater than zero
we can just return right so we'll return
false in this case
um because return false
because i don't know if you want to
handle all the keys maybe you can do it
first above here but we'll just say that
this block only works if we're dealing
with shortcuts
so what do we need well control n for
one and you can obviously design a much
more
like in-depth shortcut system maybe
that's easier to work with
but this is going to be nice and simple
so case
hzad oh what are the key code key code
uh what are my key cards man
yeah it's just key code namespace key
and it's an enum uh maybe that's so that
it can get cast
key um uh so we'll do this
if i guess if the control key is pressed
so left control it doesn't really matter
if it's left or right
um whoops so let's do left control
right control okay and then
we'll do um so uh
i don't want to do a switch on that no i
don't usually like doing this um i'll do
it this way instead so
s i forgot we were in a switch so s and
also
if a uh if input
is key pressed um key control
left control
so we can do this out here
ctrl shift
bit of improv here um so if s is pressed
and uh in this case it has to be both
control so
if control and shift then we'll actually
save file as
oh let's just do save as
um save as and then that's that
then we also have uh the n key
so just control for this one
i'll do a new scene save scene as
um i guess we can collapse these
and then uh oh was the other one right
so i'll try and do this in order maybe
so new and then open and then
so ctrl o is going to be open soon
all right um did i do something wrong
yes i did
sometimes the uh indentation is annoying
okay
so new scene open scene saves in as so
uh
let's implement the here void new scene
these are just commands so they're just
void functions void
open scene so this is going to be the
dialogue stuff obviously
and then void save scene as they're
going to affect the actual main state
so let's implement these
okay and now um if we go up
to where we had our code for all of this
stuff
so um yeah literally this is just going
to become
new scene and we paste the code here
it's going to be really cool by the way
there's this thing at the top right that
you probably can't see because of my
face cam but i'll drag it down so you
can see it's this thing
um you can actually like split this into
two
and you can actually no that's it i
think you only do two um
and this is useful because i can now
kind of scroll up here and see what my
code used to
be which is all the way over here and
then just stay down here
which is nice because i can see the file
twice you can also go like window
in like new window that will actually
open the same file twice a lot of people
don't know that
this is turning into a visual studio
tips session but anyway um this will
open the same file twice
which obviously means that um you know
you can put on a different monitor and
you can edit anyway it's pretty cool you
can keep doing that stuff
okay so open is going to
take this and then finally save as it's
going to take you this
and you can see they're all
self-contained so they all work we don't
need to change anything really
and then if we get rid of this funny
mode here
uh then we can probably make this a lot
easier
f5 let's do it
all right so now let's just try and
press ctrl o
awesome pink cube.hazel let's save that
as
a green cube
um and uh let's go ctrl n new file
control o
we've got our green cube let's open our
green cube
and maybe let's change the hue to be
like
greenish that's probably not bad 90
we'll go with 90.
so i'll go to all of these and just
change their hues to be
90. left is the last one
now we've made a green cube control
shift asks we don't have control s yet
save it as green cube control n control
o pink cube control o
green cube and everything works
wonderfully
okay so that is uh that is basically all
of our
saving file menu stuff really quite
simple as always i told you writing a
game engine was easy
um thank you guys for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video please don't
forget to hit the like button also help
support this
on patreon patreon.com um
best way to help support all this if you
like what you see and you want to see
this project evolve into something much
greater it's really the best place to
support it and i definitely appreciate
all of your support
none of this would be possible without
all of you people so thank you so much
um next time what are we doing next time
oh gizmos
right so it'd be nice to be able to like
you know select an entity and then move
it using an on-screen gizmo whether that
be like translation rotation scale gizmo
all that stuff so we're going to talk
about how on earth we're going to get
that stuff done
in the next episode thank you guys for
watching i will see you next time
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you